addressing author misconduct the role of
researchers journals and institutions
this is the first of four events in the
research without borders speak speaker
series for 2012-2013 academic year this
event is co-sponsored by Columbia's
scholarly communication program and the
Office of Research compliance and
training my name is Arthur Palmer i'm
professor in the Department of
Biochemistry and molecular biophysics at
Columbia and I also serve as the
associate dean for graduate affairs in
Columbia University Medical Center I'm
editor-in-chief of biomolecular NMR
assignments associate editor of the
journal of biomolecular NMR electronic
editor of protein science and I serve on
editorial boards for the journal of
molecular biology the Journal of
magnetic resonance and structure so you
can see I have a reason to be highly
interested in today's panel now today's
presentations a lot of the following
format each speaker will make a
presentation of approximately 15 minutes
and after that we'll open up the floor
for discussion and questions for the
audience so I ask that you hold your
questions until all of the speakers have
completed their presentations also
today's event is being webcast and
videotaped so when you ask a question
please move to the microphone that
should be in the middle of the room so
that you'll be audible on the videotape
and on the webcast so now I'd like to
introduce today's speakers Katya brosas
editor of the journal neuron an
executive editor of the neuroscience
portfolio at cell press she received the
PhD in biochemistry from UCSF and join
cell press in two thousand dr. burroughs
was appointed editorial director
review strategy at cell press in 2011
overseeing the trend group of review
journals cell presses an imprint of
elsevier and publishes 28 journals
spanning the life sciences our second
speaker is Martin Frank he's the
executive director of the american
physiological society since nineteen
nineteen eighty-five he received a PhD
in physiology and biophysics from
University of Illinois in Urbana and
prior to joining ApS dr. Frank held
faculty appointments at research
universities and positions at the NIH in
the Department of Health and Human
Services liz williams received her PhD
in 2004 from cornell university and
began her career in scientific
publishing in 2008 as associate editor
for PLoS Biology she joined the Journal
of cell biology his executive editor in
2010 the Journal of cell biology has
published published by the Rockefeller
University Press and has been an
industry leader in development of
standards for image data presentation
and for pre-publication screening to
detect misconduct and finally Naomi
schrag is the associate vice president
for research compliance in Columbia
University's office of the executive
vice president for research new sure I
received her law degree from NYU and
joined columbia in 2006 she oversees
work on issues such as research
misconduct conflict of interest in
international research compliance a
shrug also collaborates closely with
other offices across the university to
develop integrated approaches to
compliance and training so with that
introduction we'll start then with dr.
Bruce
well thank you first of all for inviting
me here today and this is a topic which
most of us who work in publishing are
really thinking about a lot these days
and spending a lot of time on so it's
great to be able to both present and get
ideas what we as publishers could be
doing better so just a bit of background
about myself I am an editor at neuron
and which is a part of cell press so a
lot of what I tried to put my
presentation is meant to be fairly
general there's portions at the end that
we'll talk a bit about how we handle
accusations and allegations of
misconduct at neuron and cell press I
should say just in advance that some of
the ways that we handle things may be
general to other publishers but I think
part of the issues in this field are
that there aren't general standards for
how publishers and institutions should
handle cases that come to rise and so
i'll just give you the the note in
advance of this i speak for cell press
and burner on probably not much beyond
that i have some three messages that i
want to bring out in the talk and
they'll be a bit of an overview
introduction so first is to define the
problem so before we can solve a problem
you're all scientists we need to know
what the problem is so what is research
misconduct and why is it a problem and
this may seem like an obvious but in
fact I think that when we discuss
misconduct there's a wide variance in
what people consider misconduct to be
I'll talk a bit about current publishing
policies approaches related to ethics
and misconduct and then towards the end
maybe lay out some opinions on how we
can start to address myths conduct both
in terms of what publishers institutions
and other bodies can do to some weed out
misconduct but maybe what we as a
scientific community can also do to try
to prevent misconduct in the first place
so defining the problem what is research
misconduct and why is it a problem this
is just some clippings within the last
couple years from the press and the view
from the press box seems to be these
days that there's a crisis in science
not just science publishing but in
science and that fraud is rampant
there's more and more cases that come to
light and get quite a
high-profile exposure the cancer
genomics case at duke in the last year
so there was the Michael Hauser case at
Harvard the stem cell the Queen's stem
cell case a number of years ago and if
you're reading all this or if you're the
public that funds us you may think you
know what what are these scientists up
to is just fraud running rampant in the
field there haven't been a lot of
studies to even try to put some numbers
on whether misconduct is actually on the
rise is it on the riser is this just a
perception that it's on the rise one
thing that has been tracked and these
two images are from what was a very nice
overview piece from carl zimmer in the
New York Times earlier this year that
has looked at retractions and
attractions are sort of documented to be
on the rise so one number that's been
put out is that retractions have gone up
tenfold while the number of publications
has gone up only forty percent so
retractions are certainly on the
increase some other studies have looked
at sort of in cases where retractions
can be analyzed through various meta
analyses and documented as to what the
retraction stemmed from are the
instances of fraud leading to retraction
up on the rise and that's less clear as
a percentage as you know as indicated
simply by the reason that's given in
retraction statements still only less
than forty percent sometimes less than
thirty percent of retractions or through
something that's documented as fraud or
misconduct as opposed to honest errors
issues of reproducibility and things
like that so is misconduct on the rise
or is this a case of a few high-profile
Road cases or even just a better ability
to ferret out fraud do we have a deeper
problem within the scientific community
so one as I've already told you it's
difficult to measure how much misconduct
there is we can talk about publications
but publications are only one part of
recent research misconduct
as it happens the number of retracted
papers is still only a very small
proportion of all the science that's
published so less than point O two
percent there are more scientists and
they're more papers but the growth and
retraction seems to be outpacing the
growth and the number of papers so that
suggests that there may be a problem
there's much more activism within the
lay press in the community to really
root out misconduct some of that is just
the nature of the internet you can find
these things quite readily blogs like
retraction watch are out there looking
for for issues and looking to bring them
to light and there's more sort of online
technology resources that can ferret out
things like plagiarism figure of
production there are also more concerted
efforts by journals and publishers to
police misconduct and ethics violations
retractions are occurring faster and
they're really reaching back deeply into
the literature so I mean certainly it's
cell press we have had allegations come
to light about things like plagiarism
and figure manipulation that go way back
because you can pick these things out
now and as I said digital electronic
media makes it easier to detect some
kinds of fraud and plagiarism but I
think it's important to point out that
there's at types of fraud and plagiarism
that are much deeper than what you can
detect with the current online resources
and I think there's some evidence you
know perhaps anecdotally that there are
more minor cases of quite what we would
call questionable conduct so sloppiness
honest errors and more of these are
coming to light and certainly I think as
an editor I'm seeing more of those in
the pre-publication review process and
you know again some forms of ethically
questionable practice and see more
widespread in the community there's been
some studies that based on self-reports
and surveys of scientists that you know
by the scientists own mouth seem to
suggest that kind of questionable
practices or in some places sort of more
accepted as the norm so does that then
translate down the road to
more attractions and more cases of
misconduct so what is research
misconduct and one message that I think
is important to put out there is that
there isn't one specific agreed-upon
definition for research misconduct there
is a common definition that is put forth
by the US Public Health Service in the
office of research integrity that sort
of isolates out three large classes of
research misconduct including
fabrication falsification plagiarism and
I think most institutions not just in
the United States but also in other
parts of the world sort of go by those
guidelines that we're talking about
fabrication falsification or plagiarism
usually with an intent to deceive so the
definitions of research misconduct
generally makes some allowance for
honest error differences opinion and you
know something like the inability to
replicate in the case of some studies
may not be considered as misconduct so
if that's the sort of hard and fast
definition of research misconduct which
I would question whether all would agree
that that's even the hard and fast
definition there's a whole range of more
gray zone situations that are I think
what people would put into the category
of questionable research practices and
these are things like failure to get
ethics or approval for animals and
subjects select abusive statistics
ignoring outliers in your data set
removing data hiding data not disclosing
conflicts of interest poor data
management authorship issues or done in
publications so whether these count as
sort of official misconduct i think is
definitely more of a gray zone and these
are the cases that i think become really
troubling and difficult for editors and
publishers to deal with so a couple
bullet points to take away is you again
sort of the official definition of
misconduct usually implies some level of
intense but intense can be hard to prove
it leaves room for honest errors or
mistakes but it's not meant to be a
justification for sloppy science and at
what point the sloppy science become you
know
close to willful intent and again we
talk about research misconduct versus
publication misconduct most research
misconduct begins well before the paper
and by the time an editor or publisher
or reviewer sees the paper you know the
damage has already been done so you know
I think we need to sort of broad and
where we start looking at research
research misconduct beyond simply the
journals however I mean it's also fair
to say that most research misconduct is
really only caught when it's published
so this ports more attention on
publication misconduct so what are some
common misconduct situations that arise
for publishers and you one thing that I
had given this talk before and had the
list of all the things that an author
could do that are unethical and I wanted
to just put out there up front that
authors are obviously not the only
component in the publication process
reviewers and editors to have ethical
guidelines that they need to hold to I'm
for the purposes of this talk I'm
focusing mostly on author misconduct but
that's not meant to imply the authors of
the only individuals in the game were
capable of misconduct so the main things
that we've been seeing it can say again
it's cell press and neuron are issues of
figure manipulation or falsification and
liz is going to talk more about that so
I won't really get into that too much a
data falsification fraud plagiarism
plagiarism comes up both for primary
research journals but also for reviews
titles duplicant redundant publication
or self-plagiarism which is you know
again quite in this gray zone so as an
author if you're using your your own
words is is that a problem and people
definitely have different opinions on
this conflicts of interest financial
professional personal the whole gamut of
potential conflicts authorship conflicts
come up I'm not infrequently for editors
so either an author who shouldn't be on
the paper or an author who was left off
of the paper failure to provide a
published reagent which
for at least cell press and most titles
I believe elsewhere is that a condition
of publication is open access to
reagents that are used or published in
that paper and the failure to provide
that is we consider that an ethics
violation generally unethical research
so violation of either leave their legal
or ethical guidelines for subjects or
materials and again you know outside of
author misconduct certainly review or
misconduct is something that you know is
very important for editors to police and
of course we as editors also have
ethical guidelines that we need to help
ourselves to so what are the journals
doing about detecting and dealing with
myth cases of misconduct when they arise
as editors and publishers so our ethical
obligation to the scientific community
into the publishing process is you know
one to support the quality and ethics of
the review process itself so
pre-publication to weed out and prevent
cases of fraud or misconduct and two to
ensure the correctness of the published
literature once it's out there so we
feel we have an obligation
post-publication to both correct and
appropriately communicate cases of
correction so at included here just some
examples of things that publishers do
generally to support these two ethical
obligations that we have is publisher so
one is most journals and publishing
houses have systems and procedures in
place for investigating and dressing
situations of misconduct I will say that
that that varies across publishers and
even within cell press I'd say that our
systems and procedures have evolved you
know largely in parallel to situations
that we've seen coming up there is
cooperation with investigations from
institutions and from funding bodies
there's probably less cooperation
between publishing houses so itself
presses a part of elsevier where you're
heavily integrated into the other
processes
at elsevier but we certainly cell press
don't spend a lot of time talking in
detail about processes for vetting these
sorts of situations with other
publishers most journals have author
reviewer guidelines for appropriate
conduct and authors are usually asked to
sign off on an understanding of those
guidelines as a requirement for
publication some journals have routine
screening on on various parameters so
journalist cell biology Liz will talk
about their pre-screening so either for
figures some journals use crap crossref
and cross-check for detecting plagiarism
and texts some journals have put out
policies for random screening of certain
types of papers so in response to the
Korean stem cell situation number years
ago science put out a policy that they
you know let it be known that they would
potentially be implementing heavier
screening of papers and certain kinds of
fields hot topics missed ordinary claims
and I think most publishers have some
sorts of efforts like this to contribute
to the education of the development of
community standards I'm either through
editorials workshops working with other
organizations in the scientific
community to set standards so how do we
address an allegation of publication
misconduct what i'll give you here is
just kind of a walkthrough of what we do
at cell press when something comes up
and i think probably elements of this
apply to other publishers but you know
again by no means do i speak for
everyone so our first course is usually
so when we get an allegation and more
typically these days the way it comes in
is maybe an anonymous reader in some
cases it might be a reviewer but if
we're talking post-publication it's
usually an anonymous reader in some
cases is a member of the lab sometimes
anonymous
sometimes or the name but an allegation
is made and so what's our first step so
our first step is usually to proceed
with some level of caution so we take
these allegations incredibly seriously
everyone is vetted but we also
appreciate that not every allegation
will turn out to be true and these kinds
of cases including just the
investigation can be incredibly damaging
to the scientists involved whether it's
the scientist who's being accused
head-on or the collateral damage for
other authors on the paper so trying to
at least in the beginning sort of dive
in the middle and be fair the authors
with fair to the allegation we initially
start with contact and initial
discussion with the authors and
reviewers that's fairly low level this
situation has come up can you give me a
response from there it usually branches
out that you start to get a sense pretty
quickly as to whether whether there's
something real here of some authors and
usually its corresponding author that
you're dealing with you know maybe
caught completely unawares but when
talking with to the postdoc or the
student are looking at the allegation
itself will see that a mistake was made
will come right to the table and say
we've got to fix this and others you
know the extremum version of others is
some obfuscation and you know what what
are you accusing me of and you can start
to as an editor kind of guide your way
through that we as these things get more
serious we will go towards notifying the
author's department university
institution funding agency or government
agencies like the Ori as is appropriate
to the case we don't at cell press
currently we have you know a certain
level of investigation of the claims but
to large degree that's left up to
investigating bodies at either the
institution the funding agency or if it
got to the point of the Ori the
rai but we don't have a mechanism for
that right now cell press this is
changing and journal and publishers i
think are taking more of this head-on
but we usually do try to work together
with the institution and funding
agencies government agencies like i said
can get involved in our betray
allegations of misconduct in the US this
is ori it gets way more complicated when
you get out of the US because most
countries don't have an agency like that
in fact it gets hard to even know where
to go for some of funding agencies we
consult with appropriate advisory
sources if necessary so whether its
internal at elsevier means certainly we
would get involved with our legal team
if that is needed we may bring the case
for agencies like cope have advisory
boards that will help our bridge it's
not so much and of arbitration but I way
to get advice on particular situations
so we may do that and in some cases if
an investigation looks like it's going
to be ongoing for a while and that we're
not going to be able to resolve the
situation cleanly in short order and we
feel there's a need to notify the
community that something is up with this
paper we may publish a note of editorial
concern to alert the community that's
something that you probably saw in the
Michael Hauser case from Harvard that
science did other papers like that would
come up as well I think it's not so
common it really is specific to a
certain circumstance but that's an
option for publisher what do we do if we
actually get through the investigation
we and/or the investigating agency find
you no hard evidence for misconduct and
fraud so if its prior to publication so
I you during the review process the
manuscript can be withdrawn from review
you know the big kind of black box there
is some authors will take that and just
submit it to the next journal so that
that's an issue that I think we as a
community you have to deal with
post-publication there are a number of
recourses that we have we
retract the paper we can as I mentioned
earlier not retract the paper so let it
stand in the literature but perhaps site
a note of editorial concern that might
be something you would do in a case
where it isn't so clear that there was
misconduct and that the Indian in the
end the investigation was we did not
decide on the side of either that
they've been absolved or shown to be
fraudulent and we might also publish in
errata or correction so in a case for
instance where there is perhaps some of
these honest errors that need to be
corrected but are not sort of sufficient
to withdraw or retract the paper we may
publish Narada a correction if an errata
is shown to be the case of papers
usually marked in the literature and
pubmed it's tagged so that you know
future readers can tell that there's
Narada if its retracted its similarly
marked and pubmed is retracted the issue
of when to retract versus correct is
very difficult and I think it does again
get into this issue of is it fraud or an
honest mistake to what extent does even
the honest mistake or in some cases the
honest mistakes really take down the
conclusions of the paper to what extent
is the data fully incorrect or
misleading or is it something that can
be corrected with no simple correction
authors can be banned from submitting to
the journal or other kinds of sanctions
editors can in some cases provide
information for others and editors and
publishers but again and I think this is
an issue worth discussing there isn't as
much sort of interaction amongst the
publishers about specific cases and we
can as a journal published an editorial
in the journal to discuss the issue
generally so usually we wouldn't
necessarily sort of highlight that
particular paper but if we feel like
there's a certain kind of behavior that
we're seeing more and more of in order
to raise awareness of the issue we can
publish an editorial think I'm proud
over my 15 minutes how am i doing for
time all right okay I'll hurry I wanted
to put out there this is probably mainly
for discussion later sort of just some
thoughts on you know what what is going
on so what why is why are we seeing
these rise in misconduct or even in my
opinion there's definitely a rise and
kind of sloppiness and I see that over
the 12 years that have been itself
pressed the degree to which papers come
in and even go through the review
process and have these you know
sometimes silly silly errors but but
important ones is rising so what you
know what's going on here is this an
individual problem or is there something
about the way research is currently
conducted or the research environment
thats are leading to these issues and
I'll just put out some things that have
been discussed is potentially factoring
into more fraud or sloppiness so one is
lack of appropriate training and
mentorship about good scientific
practice and we all know that as
scientists were largely trained in an
apprenticeship or almost osmosis kind of
situation and you are we training new
scientists in the fields appropriately
or our scientists who aren't new to the
field getting ongoing training for the
new techniques and approaches and
analytical methods they need people talk
about high pressure high stakes
environments that this puts more weight
on answers than on the process and some
people even said high-profile
publications or raise the stakes and
maybe even inadvertently promote fraud
science is competitive fast paced and
again the pressure to get results and
publish is a big deal a bigger deal than
just getting your paper and depress it's
about funding it's about keeping your
lab open does this sort of lead people
to cut corners or even commit fraud the
nature of work relationships and labs I
mean there are some labs or P eyes only
have a very indirect view of the results
and honest mistakes can quickly become
major cases of fraud if people are
trying to cover them up lack of
accountability
I think that there is an assumption in
some corners it's hard to get caught and
when you do there aren't that many
penalties the lack of institutional
ethics the feeling that everybody does
this so it seems to be okay large
collaborations I mean how many people
who have been a large copper ships
really know what all of their
collaborators are doing or know them
well enough to know whether you should
trust them scientific blindsight there's
been some credible cases of this in the
larger communion I haven't seen so much
of this in cell press but this idea that
well i'm sure my conclusions are right
and so it's okay for me to take
shortcuts because this needs to get out
there for the public good the scientific
good differences in cultural perceptions
around what constitutes fraud and
misconduct and this was is a big one as
science has become more international
it's a hard one to talk about but you
know plagiarism is a good example that
plagiarism isn't considered to be a bad
thing in all cultures and then you know
to put out there is it kind of human
nature to cheat when you can and we can
debate that none of these factors cause
fraud or I think should be used as an
excuse but they're worth considering
whether they contribute and maybe I will
skip off here but I think towards the
end it would be great to talk about as a
group kind of what what recommendations
we can make for not just the publishers
but for institutions as a whole the
community as a whole you know a few
points that I would put out there is
that we can't let even minor cases of
misconduct to get by because I do think
there needs to be a hard and fast policy
that these are the ethical lines you
don't cross them people need to know
that for their careers and when I give
talks to students I make that really
clear that just don't cross even the
little line because it's your rep your
scientific reputation is probably the
biggest thing you have is he moving
forward in your career I think the
important importance of investigating
bodies
and policy bodies at institutions can't
be underestimated and those
investigating bodies who put together
committees and institutions to look at
these cases of fraud you know really
need to pay close attention to their own
process and to potential conflicts of
interests within the institution on
these committees I mean if if you go
back on look online for some of the
cases around the the Duke case about a
year or two ago I mean there was a lot
that came out afterwards about how that
case was handled by the institutional
committee that dude that was problematic
there needs to be transparency and I
think really clear sanctions and
penalties for all to see and better
mechanisms that we as publishers take
towards letting the community know when
cases of fraud and misconduct come up
sorry that I want a bit long hopefully
that's a good introduction and I just
wanted to put that up since we're
talking about ethics and attribution is
to give you some more resources where
some of the early data that I talked
about about statistics about rise of
fraud have come up and to give some
credit to places like the society for
neuroscience and also gcb for some of
the efforts that they've made to really
publicize good practices around
publication
thank you for the opportunity to come to
columbia to participate in this panel
ethics publications ethics is something
that the society has dealt with for too
many years and what I'm here to do is to
tell you a little bit about what
processes we've undertaken and what we
are seeing within the society I also
wanted to make note as you can see ApS
is celebrating its hundred and
twenty-fifth anniversary and it's very
nice to be able to be on the campus of
Columbia University because its origins
the origin of the APS is Columbia
University College of Physicians and
Surgeons where John Green Curtis hosted
the organizational meeting for the aps
and so I'm really pleased to be able to
be here on the anniversary of the
society let me tell you a little bit
about the APS as I said we were founded
in 1887 we have about 11,000 members we
hold an annual meeting each year in the
spring with sister societies in the
Federation of American societies for
experimental biology but the important
thing is we publish scientific journals
and indeed we've been publishing since
1898 when the american journal of
physiology started at harvard university
like many of us our journals are all
online we use highwire press and we went
online in 1996 with our first journals
we scanned all the back content from
1898 to 1996 and that's available for
the user community as a legacy product
but it gives you all the literature that
we've ever published we are also
starting next year with our sister
society the physiological society we're
going to start an open access journal
that'll be called physiological reports
originally myself and my counterpart
were chuckling about the fact that the
Royal Society and the company of
biologists had not communicated with
each other and as a result there was a
journal called biology open and another
one called open biology that were
created I happen to tell my counterpart
in the UK that oh yeah we just reserved
the URL physiology open and he proceeded
to say well we just trade mark the open
physiology and I said to Philip right I
said you know it's a little ridiculous
why don't we try and do this together
and create an international journal open
access journal for physiology and
hopefully and I'll be launching early
next year one of the things I think
that's important to know is society's
generate revenue from their publications
program it's usually one of its their
primary sources of revenue in the
difference between commercial entities
and societies is that money is
reinvested in the membership in terms of
training programs awards etc designed to
recognize the next generation of
scientists and as a result of those
efforts especially in the minority arena
we were given a presidential award for
excellence in science math and
engineering mentoring back in 2003
something we would never have been able
to do if we were just generating revenue
from dues and meetings publications is a
wonderful source of revenue to
strengthen the field and the discipline
for which we represent now I was asked
to talk about ethical cases within the
aps and it's clear from this slide that
ethical cases have
then I can't doesn't work ethical cases
have been increasing since 2007 and i
will say ethical cases are anything in
which the society has to lay a hand on
it communicate with an investigator it
does it is not just say it's your cat
you said it's not something that truly
and necessarily is something that was
wrongly done there is honest error her
all over the place but we have to touch
it we have to communicate it is labor
intensive and it takes a lot of time
just as a point of reference ApS
publishes between 3,000 and 3,500 papers
a year in 2011 we had 252 cases that we
consider to be ethical cases concerns
about publication and as catchy as
indicated has been in the literature for
some time ApS is dealt with it we wrote
an editorial back in 2011 which
basically said we have to do something
about it one of the things we ended up
doing about it because a number of cases
had increased so dramatically in the
amount of time that was devoted to it we
actually hired an ethics officer a PhD
physiologist coincidentally who joined
us and is now responsible for managing
the ethics cases with our committees and
editors so how did ApS strengthen its
publications ethics process clearly it's
a multi-faceted effort it involve
publications staff and involve the
editors in chief and it involved our
publications committee we refer to the
guidelines issued by coke the committee
on publication ethics we refer to the
cses white paper on promoting integrity
and
scientific journal publications we held
an ethics retreat with our editors we
developed flow charts we developed
template letters and we developed our
review processes and I'll ask think Mike
browser and the folks at JCB and
Rockefeller press for helping to guide
us in our art review process so the
question is what can a journal do in the
case of an ethical case and obviously
the most obvious thing we can do is
reject the paper the problem with that
and I don't have an answer for it but it
is a problem that I hope we can discuss
is if I recheck the manuscript more than
likely that paper is going to go down
the street growing up in Chicago with
corner groceries I used to remember the
checks that were taped to the window of
the corner grocery store for the women
or for the people who had bounced the
check and I keep wishing that we had a
vehicle by which we could show those
authors who had bounced a check so to
speak but unfortunately our attorneys
don't like us to libel people in such
way instead we have retraction watch
which does show what's happened when a
paper has been published and ultimately
found to be an error so the other option
is alluded to is retracting the paper
you can prohibit future submissions and
indeed we do sanction authors but once
again we don't put it up on the window
to say Joe or mary has been sanctioned
and they can't publish for two years or
five years in our journal and is that
punishment because as I said they can go
down the street and publish somewhere
else more importantly for the critical
cases we can report them to the
institution because indeed we can only
do so much from our vantage point it's
really up to the institution to do the
investigation
determine whether or not misconduct has
occurred and as I said we seek guidance
from multiple formats the types of
ethics that we deal with are much like
the ones that were listed figure
manipulation prior publication duplicate
publication plagiarism human and animal
protocols authorship conflict of
interest for this talk I'm going to
focus mostly on presentation errors and
fraud and fabrication presentation
errors are what we see to the greatest
degree and it really becomes an
education process in that case this
graph shows the types of cases we've had
in how they're growing in 2010 and 2011
gives you some numbers of what we've
seen but clearly the most significant is
figure manipulation of the 252 cases
that we saw in 2011 192 of them related
to figure manipulation we try and
educate authors but as we all know
nobody reads instructions whether it's
in putting together that bike or how to
publish a paper we tell authors they
should not move remove introduce obscure
or enhance any specific feature within
an image we say authors should not
adjust contrast color balance or
brightness on less applied to the entire
figure if gels flats or fields are
grouped or rearrange then authors must
insert spaces or dividing lines to
indicate these changes and disclose the
arrangement in the figure legend authors
should not quantitatively compare
samples from different gels Blatz and
blots if this is unavoidable authors
must state in the legend that all
samples were
at the same time and processed in
parallel and if an image of the same
loading control is presented in multiple
panels this must be declared and
disclosed in the relevant legend and
once again let me thank cell biology the
Journal of cell biology for their
assistance on this as well as nature and
we do publish these in our instructions
for authors one of the reasons why we've
seen so much such a large increase in
digital imagery manipulation is because
we have instituted a process much like
the journal Cell Biology article is
accepted normally it's immediately
published online in our articles in
press in a manuscript I forth map and
published in print and online in the
copy edited and formatted page early on
what we were doing is we would post the
article in a IPS in after the fact after
was published we would do the art review
discover a lot of these presentation
errors and have to publish a core agenda
because the first publication which most
people consider to be a publication of
note in a record was problematic we have
modified our process we've moved from
doing the review after posting an
article in press to reviewing the art
after the article is accepted in before
it goes up in articles and trust that
reduces significantly
corrigenda we have to put out it doesn't
change the number of cases of figure
manipulation but it avoids the
embarrassment of having an author
publish a manuscript with figures that
have been manipulated whether
intentionally or not and saves us with
some of the difficulty and adds probably
no more than a week to the posting to
the articles in press we include within
the submission document and guidelines
the form we ask the corresponding author
three main questions that relate to the
process first adjustments the digital
images have been declared in the figure
and the legend it's a reminder to
consider that when they submit the
manuscript we say ask whether the
corresponding author indeed has seen the
raw data and takes responsibility for
the paper as a whole many of us who
published journals find the
corresponding author blaming the post
doc or the graduate student or somebody
from the collaboratory without taking
responsibility themselves but as
everyone knows all authors are equally
responsible for the content of the
journal article and even if you are
added gratuitously as an author on a
paper if there's something wrong with it
you will be charged as well and you will
suffer sanctions as well the lizard
authors have contributed to the
manuscript and take responsibility for
the
the manuscript it's something that's
critically important if you agree to be
an author on a paper so clearly the
submission process helps educate the
author we've also established a number
of courses and other activities ApS has
a professional skills training course
which is held monthly it's hosted live
and online we have a courses that focus
on writing and reviewing for journals we
writing an abstract and creating a posts
are networking at scientific meetings
and interviewing for academic positions
but most importantly we tell them what
is right and wrong when it comes to
publishing a paper a number of years ago
we created an ethics poster it is
available in multiple languages and my
president gave a president gave a
publications workshop down in Brazil and
she took a number of posters in
Portuguese on going to China in november
and i will be taking a number of posters
in china because indeed there are
cultures in which there are ethical
challenges that we as publishers have to
address because of the culture so has
that been successful I don't know one
data point doesn't convince anybody of
anything but at this point in time in
2012 we've had 107 cases and we are
projecting 161 cases about 90 less than
we did in 2012 all I know it's staff and
editors hope maybe we're making a dent
into people's thinking or perhaps all
those unethical authors are going to
somebody else's journal which I guess is
ok
they're going to you so one of the
questions that I was asked when I was
invited to participate here is
kinetically issues be addressed in a way
interestingly well let me say I don't
have an answer okay I can only give you
one anecdote an author unnamed submitted
a manuscript to the american journal of
physiology regulatory integrative and
comparative physiology the editor and
looking at that paper had some concerns
and asked us as we normally do to run
the manuscript through the Ori detection
forensic analysis and it's prob may or
may not be easy to see but what we end
up ended up seeing is there on the top a
lot of top then there were four blots
that were the same on the second and we
had two groups of three that were
identical and two singles that were
identical on the third block where the
arrows are you can see sharp
demarcations between the blots on the
left and the blacks on the right which
suggests that they were cut and pasted
together and when we went and asked the
investigator for the original captures
which is what we would
we do we receive the captured below
which was lacking a number of the blocks
that were presented clearly they were
there was pasting that went on and so we
were able to decide ultimately sadly to
reject the paper because it was never
published or this was in review but the
editor was curious if this author did it
in this paper did he or she do it
elsewhere and so our editor did a search
probably in PubMed to see if there are
other papers published and lo and behold
I discovered the same order author same
pattern and other published work and
these two papers weren't open access
journals plus one and BMC cancer we did
the Ori analysis and as you can see we
discovered duplicate bands pasting of
blots together you can see on the right
and the BMC cancer the backgrounds are
all the same wear our uniform whereas
generally you don't find you
on backgrounds in blots so clearly there
was a pattern here of an author who was
doing presentation errors we don't know
manipulating the data before it was
published and at least in the case of
these two journals they were not
ferreted out prior to the publication
process and so is it a problem I think
it is it's a real problem if you look at
all the number of all the OA journals
that are coming to the forefront some of
which are going to be utilizing
post-publication peer review which
suggests that a paper could be put out
there become part of the literature
without ethical problem being addressed
and without adequate peer review on that
note thank you and I will be more than
glad to answer questions during the end
at the end of the panel thank you
okay being the third publisher out of
three I will do my best not to be
redundant in terms of what's already
been said and so as was mentioned in the
introduction i'm liz williams i'm the
executive editor of the journal of cell
biology which is one of three journals
that's published by the Rockefeller
University Press the other two are the
journal of experimental medicine and the
journal of general physiology what I'm
going to be focusing on in the next 15
minutes is what we've been doing at
these journals to address image
manipulation so as you've just heard in
the previous two talks this is a major
source of scientific misconduct and it
also turns out that at JCP in particular
we publish a lot of images so being able
to address image manipulation at the
journal means we can address a lot of
the problems that we see I also want to
hopefully give you a sense of the next
15 minutes that although this is a big
problem and you know a lot of questions
have been raised in the previous two
talks about what we can do about this
there are actually some practical
solutions that publishers can and should
take to address image manipulation so
you've already seen some statistics
about cases of image manipulation I want
to show another example here so this is
information from John Krueger at the
office of research integrity looking at
the number of cases that Ori is dealing
with that have to do with questioned
images so these data were collected in
two year period starting in 1989 and the
latest data came out from two thousand
seven to two thousand eight so you can
see that in 1989 there were very few
cases less than five percent of the
cases that they were looking at they
were dealing with questioned images but
look now ahead to 2007-2008 and you're
talking about more than sixty percent of
their cases so image manipulation is not
a new phenomenon but something like this
tells you it's an increasingly visible
one
so why do scientists manipulate images
some of this has already been touched on
and I'll just give you our perspective
on it I think one of the major
contributors is that we live in a
culture where image manipulation is
considered to be acceptable so I'm
showing you a quote here from 1994 from
the managing editor of Time magazine at
that time he said every major news
outlet routinely crops and retouches
photos to eliminate minor extraneous
elements so long as the essential
meaning of the picture is left intact
now that last phrase about the essential
meaning of the picture is where things
get very questionable you know very ugly
there's a lot of gray there and I also
want to point out this was a quote from
1994 this is very early in the Photoshop
days and if you look at popular media
today everything has been retouched
before you see it most people don't even
post photos to facebook without even
touching them up so our culture if
anything is accepting image manipulation
more and more and of course that's going
to be reflected in scientific culture I
think another reason that image
manipulation happens is that it's
extremely easy to do with tools such as
Photoshop which are now in just about
everybody's hands what we see a lot of
is a contribution of something between
naivet or ignorance or incompetents on
the part of scientists and this comes in
sort of two flavors first of all there's
a lot of misunderstanding on the part of
scientists in terms of where the line is
between what is acceptable and what's
unacceptable and there's also just a lot
of misunderstanding about the actual
tools that they are using either to
capture their images or to process them
and then as other people have mentioned
there is probably in some cases a
deliberate intent to deceive when
scientists are manipulating images but I
do think that this is probably the
minority
cases so image manipulation happens
whether we like it or not and the
question then is whose responsibility is
it to detect it and i would say that
there are basically five major groups
that we should consider the principal
investigators who are in the lab looking
at the research itself the reviewers
looking at these data before publication
editor's such as myself at journals the
readers of papers after publication and
then a group that I call citizen
screeners which is sort of an emerging
group of people some of whom have
scientific training and some of whom
don't who are out there actually just
trawling through the scientific
literature looking for cases of image
manipulation I would say there are
really only two groups at these five
that should be bearing the bulk of the
responsibility that is the principal
investigators who are the first line of
defense in the lab looking at the
original data and making sure it is
presented properly in a publication and
then editors such as myself now this is
not to say that reviewers and readers
and citizen screeners don't play an
important role in identifying cases of
image manipulation but as a whole they
are too heterogeneous of a group in
terms of their training and their time
commitment to do it systematically which
is really what has to be done so what
then is a journals role in this as has
been touched on in the earlier talks
journals have a responsibility to their
readers to the scientific community into
the public as a whole to do i would say
three main things it's our
responsibility to ensure to the best of
our ability that what our readers see is
what the authors saw it's our
responsibility to ensure the quality of
the science that we polish and it's our
responsibility to maintain the integrity
of a scientific record so when it comes
to image manipulation what does that
mean for a journal but we feel very very
strongly at the Rockefeller University
Press that journals have
responsibilities both before publication
and after publication before publication
they have a responsibility to detect as
much manipulation as possible and
unfortunately most journals have not
actually
taking on this responsibility in order
to do this there are four major elements
that journals have to have in place they
have to have guidelines screening
enforcement and reporting so in terms of
guidelines these are well-publicized
guidelines about data presentation as
Marty just touched on for aps and i will
show you JCB's which are very similar
because there is a derived from ours a
journal must have systematic screening
and enforcement of those guidelines
simply having guidelines without forcing
them is meaningless and a journal must
be willing to report cases of potential
fraud to the relevant authorities now
I'm not going to stand up here and claim
that JCP catches all cases of image
manipulation that come through the door
so after publication JCB like every
journal has a responsibility to respond
to all allegations that come their way
be they from an anonymous source or
otherwise so as I said there are these
four major elements guidelines screening
enforcement and reporting so what I'm
showing here are JCB's guidelines for
data presentation these are publicly
available on our website through our
instructions for authors I'm not going
to go through them in detail but I just
want to emphasize as Marty did that it's
very easy to put these guidelines out
there they're very straightforward this
doesn't have to be a complicated task
but just having the guidelines is not
enough so as I said there must be
screening enforcement and reporting so
JCB was has been an industry leader in
this case we have been systematically
screening all images in all editorially
accepted papers for ten years now
whenever we there is a potential
violation of our guidelines we
investigate that and we do revoke
acceptance of papers when unacceptable
manipulation is detected and when
appropriate we also will report authors
to their institution
so now to give you a little bit of
practical information about how we
actually do this I don't want this to
seem as if it's a very complicated task
that journals can't take on it really is
very straightforward what we use for our
image screen is Adobe Photoshop this is
the preferred tool for manipulating your
images and it's also what we found to be
the most reliable tool for detecting
manipulation in very practical terms how
do we do this we have a production
editor who screams the each image in
every paper manually she's very simple
dynamic brightness and contrast
adjustments levels adjustments to look
for any atypical or inconsistent pixels
in an image now very importantly this
person is not trained in science because
her job is purely to look for a typical
pixels she also will do manual visual
scans to look for duplicated data and
just a general unbiased scan of the
figures to look for anything out of the
ordinary any red flag now in terms of
the actual commitment that a publisher
has to make to do this type of screening
it is not all that large so at the
Rockefeller University Press we publish
about 700 papers per year across our
three journals and we have the
equivalent of one full-time person who
does all of this screening that's really
not asking a lot of a publisher so what
do we then do after we've done the
screening how do we enforce our
guidelines the first step is to ask for
the original data from the authors and
this can be in the form of unmodified
microscopy files radiographic films
whatever data underlying underlie the
figure that we're looking at at this
point a trained scientist has to be
involved and it's a trained scientist
who looks at those data and the prepared
figure and the reason you need a trained
scientist involved is that there are
different kinds of manipulation so the
bulk of what we see is what we call
inappropriate manipulation this is
manipulation that does not affect the
interpretation of the data but it does
violate our guidelines for data
presentation the resolution here is very
straightforward the authors remake their
figures using the original data in such
a way that our guidelines are followed
in a much smaller number of cases we see
what we call fraudulent manipulation so
this is fabrication or falsification
that actually affects the interpretation
of the data and this is why a scientist
has to be involved to actually look at
those data look at the manipulation and
ask whether it has undermined any of the
conclusions if we find that any
conclusion in a paper is undermined by
the manipulation we revoke acceptance so
now the question is how big of a problem
is this actually and is this worth doing
so JCB has been doing this
systematically for 10 years and to my
knowledge this is the only set of data
that a systematic study of image
manipulation at a journal over time in
an unbiased manner what we've seen over
these ten years is that about half of
our authors have to remake at least one
figure and that can be for a simple
reason as one of the images isn't high
enough resolution for us to actually do
our screaming or it can be something
much more complicated more than fifteen
percent of our authors have to provide
some level of original data for
assessment and this can be anything from
a single film to dozens and dozens of
images it really depends on the case and
then the critical number here is that
one percent of all editorial accepted
papers at JCB end up having acceptance
revoked or the authors withdraw the
paper once we start asking questions so
that might not seem like a very big
number but let me give you the actual
raw numbers here so in 10 years we have
screened 3478 papers we've requested
original data in 572 cases and we have
revoked acceptance so the authors have
withdrawn 37 papers so in asking how big
of an issue this is I would ask you what
the ramifications the scientific
community might have been if JCP had
published about four papers per year and
it we in which at least one of the
conclusions was not supported by the
so there's a point I want to make about
these data that we've been collecting
over 10 years and that is that this one
percent this frequency of fraudulent
image manipulation has remained
completely constant over 10 years at JCP
despite the fact that we are very very
vocal of other image screening policies
so one interpretation of that might be
that systematic screening is not
actually a deterrent and so that might
discourage some journals from doing this
but I would like to emphasize that the
fact that it's not a deterrent does not
undermine the responsibility that
journals have to protect the scientific
record so this is something that needs
to be done so I just want to briefly
mention another initiative we have at
JCB to promote image integrity JCB
launched in 2008 the JCB data viewer
this is a browser based system for
actually hosting the original image data
that underlie are published images so
now instead of readers just having to
look at a small 2d version of a figure
in a PDF they can actually go in and
look at interact with the original data
underlying some of those figures which
really allows the reader to ask do these
data represent what the authors actually
are showing
so as was mentioned before image
manipulation is just one kind of fraud
and I really want to emphasize although
there are very very very practical
things that journals can do to look at
image manipulation and prevent it and
although this is a major source of
scientific misconduct this is only a
fraction of what is out there so what
I've been talking about here is
detecting post-acquisition image
manipulation but image manipulation can
occur upstream with that tube it can
occur at the stage at which you decide
how to take a picture of something or it
can occur at the stage where you decide
whether to take a picture of something
and that's something that we
unfortunately cannot scream for
importantly images are only one form of
scientific data graphical data numerical
data there simply are no easy tools for
screening these for manipulation and
data manipulation is of course only one
form of misconduct as you've heard in
produce two talks plagiarism failure to
obtain regulatory board approval all of
these things are things that journals
have to be on the lookout for but
between plagiarism and image
manipulation these are two major forms
of scientific misconduct that Journal
see and they're actually two forms of
misconduct that we can detect through
very practical measures thank you
it's the only non scientists on the
panel I'd like to start by saying you're
not going to see so many pictures in
these slides Oh lawyers being more tax
oriented sometimes see
okay so and being a lawyer I'm going to
start with what are the rules because
institutions as institutions we are
governed by rules and regulations that
tell us what to do when as you hear a
journal editor or a journal reader or a
graduate student or a faculty member or
a peer reviewer comes to us and says I
think there might be a problem and in in
two thousand the Office of Science and
Technology Policy developed a sort of
overarching policy that was supposed to
be implemented by all of the federal
granting agencies with respect to
research misconduct and so they're after
the Public Health Service in issued its
policies on research misconduct the
National Science Foundation adopted
parallel policies FDA is now actually
proposing its own regulations and each
of these entities has adopted
regulations that are very consistent in
some ways but that have nuanced
variations so for us as institutions it
can be complicated we all of these in
these federal level regulations require
us to establish an institutional policy
so we all have such policies and they
generally track the regulations in one
way or another as ours does the
definition as Katya mentioned the
regulatory definition that most of us
have adopted is what we call F F and P
fabrication falsification or plagiarism
and I want to point out that the
definition spans the whole life span of
the project from proposing research to
the final published manuscript so we
have in on occasion institutions receive
concerns raised by a granting agency
reviewing a proposal where there's a
concern that the proposal itself before
any research has even been conducted has
somehow contains research misconduct
either plagiarism or some other kind of
research misconduct and and it and and
and even in the reviewing process
someone who is reviewing proposals for a
federal agency can also be found to have
committed research misconduct if for
example they plagiarize something that
they've reviewed so what do those words
mean that we in in this research
misconduct context focus on within the
institution well again there are
regulatory definitions that we look at
fabrication making up data or results
falsification the manipulation that
you've been hearing about of images but
it could also be other kinds of
manipulation of equipment or processes
to conduct research so that the research
is not accurately represented and then
plagiarism which you've also heard about
already so these are the way that
Columbia characterizes or defines these
terms but like I said this is really how
the federal regulations define these
terms and as federally funded
institutions we're obligated to have
policies that conform to the regulations
so what is not research misconduct is
just as important and again because as
an institution we have very specific and
structured processes that would follow
for research misconduct it's important
for us to be able to explain what is not
included and so you've heard about
honest error and differences of a pin
over data interpretation authorship
disputes are not issues that
institutions typically will handle
through a research misconduct process
and we don't other kinds of violations
are bad behavior again not research
misconduct where we have very specific
processes these issues those kinds of
violations need to be addressed through
an appropriate institutional channel but
it just wouldn't be this one so what is
that process that I've been alluding to
well it is um it has a number of phases
that will begin with a written
allegation and in at our institution we
require a written allegation it must
include some basis for why there's a
belief that the issue that's been
observed or the concern instant factor
could be could be research misconduct
and when we get an allegation like that
after we do kind of an initial
assessment to make sure that it really
they really are talking about potential
research misconduct and not one of those
other kinds of issues the first step is
to convene an inquiry committee and so
the first phase of this process is what
we call an inquiry again it's a
regulatory term it's a preliminary
review it's a quick look to determine
whether there's a need for further
investigation then a potential second
phase is an investigation after that
there's an adjudication which is where
the institution ultimately the vested a
person with vested with authority to do
so adjudicates whether there's an actual
finding or not and if there is a finding
our institution there may be an appeal
so I want to spend a little bit of time
just describing what happens at
particularly Lee the inquiry phase and
then the investigation phase and each of
these are are carried out by a faculty
committee so we find people with the
relevant expertise we assure that they
do not have conflicts of interest and we
have a an SOP that we follow for that
and and and they are doing this in
addition to their full-time work at
Columbia and sometimes this can be very
time consuming and it can it can even
just the scheduling alone can be
challenging so at the inquiry stage as I
said it's a quick look it's kind of like
the grand jury it's looking to see
whether the allegation has substance and
whether a full investigation is
warranted and we have a committee that
look at that and ultimately draft a
report with a recommendation at our
institution we have an overarching
standing committee that then can accept
or reject that report so if there's a
recommendation to carry out a full
investigation when we move into a much
more formal and exhaustive examination
of the research record and in parallel
with that inquiry in fact one of the
very first things that we do
upon receiving an allegation is figure
out what are the research records here
and how can we collect them so there is
an obligation again under the
regulations and in our policy for us to
go out and collect whatever research
records may be relevant to this case
that could be lab notebooks that could
be copies of somebody's hard drive that
could be printouts there are any number
of records that we may gather and in
some big cases there may be thousands of
pages of documents that we ultimately
collect and electronic files that need
to be reviewed so in an investigation
those materials are analyzed and in
addition people are interviewed so you
heard that in typically and under the
regulations and our policy there is an
intent requirement the the the action
has to have been for to be research
misconduct the person has to have done
it intentionally or recklessly and that
means that you the investigators have to
talk to that person and also to other
people who may have worked with that
person or who may have seen we have
observed certain kinds of things or who
may have never observed anything all of
those kinds of issues come into play at
this level the investigation is
conducted by a whole new faculty
committee again a committee of experts
in the area at times we may go outside
the institution to have an expert from
outside become part of the committee it
is an enormous undertaking as
as anyone who's participated in this
kind of process it is exhaustive and it
also results ultimately in a report now
the investigation report may be anywhere
from 20 to 100 pages long depending on
the scope depending on the nature
depending on whether there are findings
or not they often have figures in them
explanations examples if there is a
finding that somebody actually
fabricated or falsified data how can we
show that how can we see that here's the
before and here's the after of the
manipulated the manipulated output from
the research or here's the raw data and
here's the data that was put into the
excel sheet that was ultimately used to
generate the statistics that are
published so it is a very it is very
painstaking and careful process and
again it is one that takes time in some
cases we've had cases that have spanned
research that was conducted over five or
six years many different publications in
many journals an investigation like that
takes time ultimately again this report
is reviewed by the hour standing hour at
our institution our overarching Standing
Committee on the conduct of research and
then the final phase would be the
adjudication by at our institution
that's by our executive vice president
for research who has before him the
report their recommendation from the
Standing Committee and any comments to
the report by the complainant the person
raising the issue in the first place and
also the respondent
each of those individuals has the
opportunity to comment on the draft of
all of these reports so it is a process
laid in process and i can say that as a
lawyer evan and we and and there are a
lot of safeguards that that we abide by
to try and ensure that it's a fair
process because as you've also heard and
as everyone knows the consequences of
findings of research misconduct or even
an allegation of research misconduct can
be so significant and that's why
confidentiality of this process is also
so critical so there can be a period
where a journal may come to us with a
concern and we may say okay we're going
to we have a process we have a policy
here it is we're going to treat your
concern in accordance with our process
and then we may not be able to say
anything until we complete this process
and you'll see when I a little later
i'll talk about the notifications that
an institution may be involved with at
the end of the process but there can be
this sort of lag time and it can be
frustrating too many people involved
because people want to know what's going
on but we on the institution side we
can't really talk about it there there
are many limitations on what we could
share even to acknowledge that for
example there is an investigation as
opposed to an inquiry could potentially
be a breach of confidentiality so we're
very careful about that and that is to
protect everyone not only the person
raising the issue and the person against
whom the issue is raised but also people
participating in the process witnesses
committee members
no on specific safeguards that we have
in place that are again in our policy
for the complainant is overall truth
them fairly and reasonably protect the
complainant from retaliation and that's
absolutely critical so as an institution
Columbia has an overall policy not to
tolerate retaliation in this context
it's especially important and we're very
attentive to that and then if there are
ever concerns and sometimes there could
be concerns that the complainant might
have about their own reputation for
having raised an issue that diligent
efforts would be made to protect or
restore for that person the respondent
is also entitled to significant
protections and start being starting
with the presumption of innocence so you
know our starting place as we start
collecting all of these records and
putting all these committees together in
the starting place for each of the
committee's is this person is presumed
not to have committed research
misconduct and then burden of proof is
on the institution to show that the
person did they have to be protected
from penalty and public knowledge until
they're found culpable so this goes back
to the confidentiality that I mentioned
and in general they're entitled to
continue working to continue to function
in the university unless there are some
compelling an exceptional situation
a finding of research misconduct has to
meet certain requirements and these are
again regulatory and and incorporated in
our policy so there has to be a
significant departure from accepted
practices in the relevant research
community and that's important because
from where I sit I'm a university-wide
roll Medical Center non medical center
issues and there are different practices
in different disciplines so members of
the discipline in the committee's will
be able to make that kind of assessment
there is this intent requirement it has
to the action has to have been taken
intentionally knowingly or recklessly
and that is hard to prove but it has
been proven it can be proven in some
cases and I think you know it's right
that it's hard to show because it goes
to the heart of really what what we're
what we're trying to do here and then
finally there is a standard of evidence
that applies and this is a legal term
the preponderance of the evidence the
the preponderance of the evidence has to
show that there should be a finding of
research misconduct so that means it
really comes down to more likely than
not does the evidence show more likely
than not that this person intentionally
knowingly or recklessly falsified or
fabricated or plagiarized it's the civil
standard not the criminal standard it's
not beyond a reasonable doubt so you
know that you can sometimes be troubling
or difficult in those instances where a
finding is made we we do provide
notifications
and under our policy and under the regs
but this again occurs only at the end of
the process and journals are of course
among those to whom a notification might
be required but typically we will reach
out to in a situation like this and I
think institutions will typically reach
out to the corresponding author assuming
that person is not necessarily involved
with the case and and you know it's an
awkward position in some ways for the
institution because we typically don't
involve ourselves between authors and
journalists we typically rely on authors
and journals to talk to each other so
there's some awkwardness for the
institution to on the one hand ensure
that the scientific record the
literature is appropriately remedied
where there's an issue without sort of
stepping on the toes of the authors and
the journals in their process so we will
provide information and be available for
consultation but also our report itself
may remain confidential so the journal
sometimes might want to see the report
and we might not be able to provide it
or we might provide an excerpt or a
redaction redacted version because of
the sensitivities that are involved now
ultimately if there's a finding of
research misconduct under HHS funded
research the report goes to the office
of research integrity which does its own
review and if they make a finding they
will pop
push that in the Federal Register
retraction watch and some of those blogs
that's one of their sources is the
Federal Register and on occasion there
are there are folks who will FOIA the
federal agencies for information about
these cases so that's another way that
sometimes information ends up being
revealed the sanctions what are the
sanctions with someone is found to have
committed research misconduct after one
of these processes well from the federal
side there are voluntary kinds of
resolutions and then there are
involuntary resolutions and the the
voluntary resolutions can involve
exclusions and settlements with the
government where someone might agree
voluntarily not to apply for funding for
a certain period of time not to serve on
advisory committees to the funding
agencies or peer review to work under
supervision for some period there is
also debarment and so sometimes the
outcome of a finding of research
misconduct is that an individual is
barred from eligibility for any federal
funding or participation in any process
advisory or study section or any other
such process for some period of time it
can be one year it can be three years it
can be five years depending on the
severity on the university side there
are other kinds of sanctions that could
ultimately end up being invoked and of
course those sanctions have to go
through university processes that are
you know in some cases it may be
separate from a research misconduct
investigation but those kinds of things
could be retraction of degrees so if
there are graduate student
were found of falsified portions or
significant portions of their thesis it
could be there could be other kinds of
sanctions as well but again these are
the kinds of things that typically as is
typical for institutions in general
there are layers of a process so for
those of you in the room who may be
students or postdocs and faculty at
Columbia and wonder what to do if you
have a concern or a suspicion there are
there are a number of different avenues
but you know I we should talk to someone
and there are lots of places where you
can go if you can't talk to the
researcher themselves or colleagues that
you trust department chairs leadership
there's always my office we we counsel
people we talk through issues and talk
through hypothetical questions and we're
happy to do that colombia's Ombuds
office similarly can provide some help
there and at many institutions including
Columbia we have a compliance hotline
where people can make anonymous reports
so there are avenues and I think it's a
very difficult situation to be in so
folks should know they're not alone this
is the only picture and my slides this
is our website and there's lots of
information about how this process works
here
so I'd like to invite our panelists to
take seats up in front and then we'll
open the floor for questions and
discussion there's a microphone now in
the center of the room so if we have a
question move to microphone
well everyone
communicate with journals and it might
be very helpful for us if your
committees did communicate with journals
didn't just rely on the authors to
communicate with actually I didn't say
we don't I said that we do it in
coordination with the authors so what
can happen and has happened is a letter
might go to a corresponding author and
another letter might go to the editor of
that journal outlining the same issues
just so that that editor is aware and
then we would work together with the
corresponding author hopefully to try
and address the issue but if there is
you know I mean ultimately the
institution is very concerned that the
literature be corrected and if there's a
lack of responsiveness then we will go
directly to the to the journal if we
need to so my kind of asked my my
question so let's get different one
which is the Marty you commented a bit
about the the open access policy would
you say that and you know that that that
was a question of the journals being
open access that allowed for this or
that there was in those cases a lower
threshold for some kind of review
process that was going on and that that
could happen open access or not hey it
could happen whether it's open access or
not clearly it's a function of the rigor
that the publisher puts into ensuring
that the scientific literature is
correct as Liz indicated lives in
journal of cell biology has been at the
forefront I think you have three of us
up here
news publications philosophy are to
ensure the integrity of science sadly
there are over 5,000 scientific journals
published I don't think most scientific
publishers undergo the same level of
rigor that we undergo when we look at a
paper many of them do spot checks I
think that's good but I think it's
critically important to look at all the
figures with respect to figure
manipulation with respect to open access
I think we have seen such a flood of new
journals coming into the marketplace
that are open access with the primary
incentive to try and hold down offer
processing charges and to publish the
paper as quickly as possible that the
time necessary to ferret out problems is
not necessarily there or not necessarily
in the interest of some publishers and
as such i think we run the risk of
seeing an increasing number of problems
like I guess I have a related comment
but it's not so much specifically about
open access journals but an interesting
other development in the field of
scientific communication is this idea of
pre print servers just put the stuff out
there and buyer beware and and you know
let the community validate it we don't
we don't need publishers at all and I
guess I sit on the other side of that
and agree with the other speakers here
that there's much that publishers bring
to the scientific communication process
obviously but one thing is to ensure the
sanctity of the record and I think an
issue that isn't discussed a lot with
these ideas of institutional
repositories preprint servers
pre-publication is you know who is
quality around those records and they
are out there just as much as the
published papers are so so I put that
out there the only thing I would add is
just that we need to differentiate the
quality of peer review from the quality
of post peer review checking of the sort
that I was talking about in my talk that
marty was talking about in terms of what
they're doing as well you know there are
some very rigorous journals out there in
terms of peer review that are not doing
image checking plagiarism checking
things like that so I think we need to
make sure we're very clear about
distinguishing open access versus rigor
of peer review versus other types of
screening I'd like to return to an issue
that was touched on briefly and that is
in modern science so much of the work is
collaborative and there may well be
authors on the paper who are responsible
for very technical matters such as
statistical analysis or very highly
specialized chemical analyses how are
the responsibility of the other authors
viewed by journals I was raised as an
absolutist that every author was
responsible for every word in the paper
and one of my very first paper is a
graduate student I cited a journal
article that was only available in
French and my PhD advisor was incredibly
concerned over whether I read French
well enough to absolutely know that
article well enough to cite it but the
situation has changed a lot with all of
these new techniques no one's is an
expert in all of them so how does this
pertain to authors responsibilities
as I think I indicated it is critically
important that all authors are familiar
with the content of the article because
if there is a problem at least for a PS
and I think most the the three the two
other publishers up here each author is
held accountable for the content of that
paper unfortunately I think science had
become I got my doctorate centuries ago
in 1973 when you actually had to
calculate data yourself and analyze
printouts and things of that nature now
so much comes out the a computer
algorithm that too many of the
investigators really don't know what
goes into now algorithm algorithm and
too many pies don't spend enough time in
the laboratory to talk with their
graduate students postdocs and
technicians to actually figure out what
they're doing in the lab and how the
data is being acquired and so I think
there is a real risk that we become too
big in science the research groups have
become too big in the potential for
malfeasance exists out there
I mean I would also say that I in the
end if a journal chooses to retract a
paper they retract the paper they don't
retract one author on the paper but the
entire paper is retracted i think that
there's sensitivity around some of those
issues in that we do attempt to work
with the authors on the paper in the
retraction statement and in that
statement that there can be a subtlety
to it that makes clear who was
responsible for which experiments or
which experiments are in question but
the paper as a whole is retracted and so
I do think investigators should be aware
that when you're entering collaborations
you rise with it and you fall with it
and I think probably as important is
having a technical awareness of the data
in the paper is knowing your
collaborators and sort of the ethical
mores that your collaborators hold I
mean I had a situation where it was
three collaborating labs on a paper that
had issues that ultimately led to
retraction that fell around figure
manipulation and it was just two of the
co-authors were just stunned at the
co-author who was responsible for that
piece of data but they you know they all
went through the process together it was
extremely difficult for all authors
involved especially the authors who just
felt like they had been blindsided by
this but learned a good lesson I think
but ultimately the whole were paper is
retracted not an individual author but
to follow up some journals now require
statements as to who did what any strike
me has dead out of jail free cards of a
kind it's letting gives people an excuse
to say I wrote I did x I'm not
responsible for why
we don't currently have those that sell
price although I have to say that
personally I'm in favor of them I mean
probably for other reasons I think that
there are papers where if you had that
level of statement what would float to
the top would be the persons who really
did nothing on the paper we're on it
just fortuitously and I mean think the
case that showed this quite well was the
the stem cell papers in science where
there were tons of corresponding authors
on those papers and they just fell off
as soon as trouble arose right so I
think knowing your collaborators for
bigger reasons than just publication is
really important you're standing by
their data as much as you're standing by
arilinn
my question is about what happens after
the papers retract after papers
retracted and really around the issue of
retracted papers continue to be cited
and is there any mechanism I wonder
where by you know you're vetting the
papers you get to see their citations
are they citing retracted papers I can
speak to that I mean our production
department has a system in place to
check all citations to make sure they do
not refer to retracted papers or if they
do they make it clear that the data were
retracted so they paper published in any
of our journals cannot refer to data
prep in a retracted paper as fact you
can refer to the fact that the paper was
retracted but that's all and that's the
case across the board I think that's in
general the same thing the biggest
problem is keeping track of all the
papers that are retracted rah and as you
know there was a study recently done i
think phil davis did the study to look
at the publication record in whether or
not journal site breach at have the
retractions appropriately noted with the
PubMed has appropriate linkages to
corrigenda and retracted papers in it's
not a hundred percent unfortunately it
was pretty high actually I think it's
something about so many person yeah no
it wasn't a hundred percent okay another
question a lot of slightly different
tack do you think that the adoption of
data plan and data management plan
requirements and as those maybe move
towards having you know teeth on the end
do you think those will help improve the
situation around you know at least
making it easier to have that sort of
post peer review process and sure the
data are not being overly massage door
manipulated it will certainly help with
investigations yes
I don't know that it'll that it will
prevent any problems or reduce them but
the number of authors I've dealt with
who say we can't find the data right
it's quite high and unfortunately for us
that means we we revoke acceptance if
you cannot find the original data so you
know for some authors it will save them
if it can actually find the original
data and respond properly to our
questions okay thank you could I just
ask a quick question of my panelists as
I indicated a PS i had 252 cases last
year which we consider deaf but we
actually only sanctioned eight
investigators age authored groups when
we sanction we sanction all the amount
thurs and I'm curious whether or not the
same is true for both of your
publications we do not sanction or black
those two people we would but we haven't
in my recent and as I said we sanctioned
usually anywhere from one to five years
depending on the severity but as I
indicated in my comments earlier that
sanction only means that Joe or Mary can
submit another manuscript to the APS
they can't review either they can go to
other journals and we have no way of
communicating that to the community and
I think that's one of the failings and
I'm not sure my attorneys would let me
just post it on our website which would
you a review would you have referred all
those cases back to the author's
institution yes we usually do yeah yes I
wanted to ask some questions from the
other end of the process from that of
the clinical papers and
part of my background outside of
colombians with pharmaceutical ad
agencies that do not do the TV ads and
Big Pharma most of this I think is
asking mr. Palmer the sloppiness has is
sometimes generated by language often
there are abstracts that because the
grammatical errors are going to put out
of business codeine or something this
seems to be something unchanging and in
my sense and i'm not sure that
grammatical grasp and the like are
better now than they were 20 years ago
so that's all there are comment and as
for plagiarism my experience and i think
those people who have taught how the
same experience can be almost accidental
I remember trying to track down a
Russian article from 19-9 and the new
york academy didn't have it and then
Google came to mind this was some time
ago and lo and behold it was a quite
elderly doctor who was quoting a
paragraph from a previous publication of
his with this 99 Russian whatever and it
was published by a major medical
publishing house so I had a little chat
with his secretary about whether this
was truly essential and I'm sure you
have anecdotes of that sort where there
was really no intent I want to make a
comment actually I'd like to hear from
from the group of you industry Big
Pharma in many cases has copy reviews
and
this may suggest something of the
usefulness of FDA regulation I don't
know how many of you know what this
entails but usually it's all the writers
whether their in-house or ad ad agencies
all the in-house editors there can be
one or two a product director a product
manager because for whatever the drug is
the drug developer at least one md a
lawyer who's often silent for reasons
I've never understood and matters are
gone through line by line in word by
word for both promotional from the FDA's
point of view and non promotional
materials now what wasn't covered in any
of this but is mentioned is the effort
it's mentioned in the falsification the
deletion of materials I mean now that we
have a clinical trials more or less
online that there's less of that and
data on file and many cases have to be
assumed but with those two provisos it
seems to me at least that in the
experience of some of us industry has
tried very very hard to do something
that that's that is a true and within
within the regulations so I'd like your
reactions certainly as someone who runs
a laboratory the question
of what piece of data is data that
disproves what hypothesis we hold dear
and what is a glitch from something that
just was done wrong is critically
critically important that's what keeps
you awake because if you leave out the
critical piece of information that told
you you were wrong you'll obviously
never know you were wrong and a large
number of the cases that I know of in
the literature have to do with pieces of
data that were ignored that would have
told people that there was a problem
with the conclusions they were drawing
and it's not only the people are kind of
consciously making the decision to hide
this data of course people are in many
cases are trying to draw a line between
what's noise what's a glitch and what's
real and you know it's easy to draw the
line on the side of the boundary you
know that favors what you're hoping for
so I think that's a terrific alee
difficult problem and made even larger
by the quantity of data one acquires now
want to choir so much data that is
virtually impossible to look at every
single peak or every single measurement
and then of course one starts to rely as
Marisa automated procedures for
evaluating the data and then of course
any collision the automated procedure
leads to problems down the road so I
don't have an answer to that other than
the fact that also was alluded to the
corresponding authors have to sit down
and look at the raw data
other comments on this topic I mean I
agree it's an incredibly hard issue that
I think independent of the misconduct
issues that we as editors deal with
often when you especially have cases
where papers are revised and resubmitted
and authors are asked to address certain
questions and it's frequent that people
will come back and say well we tried the
experiment but it didn't work so what
does that really mean the other place it
does come up you know again it's
somewhat related to but also separate
for misconduct is it's not it's not
heard of that journals get allegations
that are more about what we couldn't
replicate that paper so you know it
should be retracted or it's fraudulent
and inability for another lab to
replicate a paper is not the same as as
fraudulent or misconduct those still
need to be looked at carefully by the
journals but it you know it only in some
cases will evolve into an ethical
misconduct issue so but it's it's it's
challenging i mean i think willfully
removing data that speaks against your
conclusions is in that grey zone of bad
behavior but only in some cases would it
be unethical
I had a question for a very camera with
nature publishing group for Naomi we've
talked a little bit i mean several
panelists have talked about the
importance of training and mentoring in
avoiding and in finding those sources of
misconduct you've talked about the
consequences for people who are found to
have committed misconduct I was
wondering what in your experience here
at Columbia or if you know from other
universities what are the consequences
or what is the what are the measures
that are put in place after that for the
laboratory for the p.i in whose labs
misconduct happened and all that is
there some form of constructive dealings
with with these situations after the
fact so it's a great question that
really goes kind of as you say beyond
the research misconduct regulatory
procedure that we in my office worry
about it and have responsibility for
that really goes to the nature of the
mentoring and the teaching and the
supervision and I think you know most
institutions look to that as a kind of
Provost real issue and there can be
steps that can be taken by a department
or a school or a Dean or a Provost to to
look at to look at those kinds of
questions and perhaps to make
recommendations about changes or
remediation or training or other kinds
of things they think it is case specific
and I think institutions vary in how
they handle it and because that side of
things is not regulated
you know from my perspective I mean
since my role is primarily a regulatory
role I have less involvement with that
side although I you know someone in my
kind of role the edit at an incident at
a research institution is often asked
for just advice and informal counsel you
know what's a good approach how should
this be addressed now we've reached two
o'clock so we have time for one last
question I see someone about to get up
yeah I hi I actually have a question
from Twitter and fee Martin so Irene
Hames who works in the UK as a peer
review specialists she's interested in
the APS's ethical officer role just
wondering about the details of that role
what does that involve most most of the
ethical cases we deal with have been
dealt with previously through our
committee structure and staff does the
investigation the committee addresses
the issues we just found it becoming
such a burden on volunteer staff or
volunteer members of committees one of
the things i tell my directors is that
all their committees and all the
committee chairs are serving as
volunteers actually have full-time jobs
for which they get paid and it's
incumbent on us to minimize the low down
there on them so that they can do what
they're really getting paid to do so we
decided it was important to bring a
person in house to help to do the
investigations and share it out the
problems do the communications with the
authors to get the original capture data
when need
to communicate with the institution or
appropriate etc so join me in thanking
all of our panelists and I'm sure
they'll be welcome to continue the
discussion after a formal clothes of
today's session